3 | Une pile de cartes qui tend vers l’infini
?
Jusqu’où peut aller la pile de cartes ? Y
a-t-il une limite théorique à la distance
que que peut atteindre une pile de carte ? Ou,
à l’inverse, est-il théoriquement possible
de faire tendre cette pile de carte aussi
loin que l’on veut, sans que cette pile
ne perde l’équilibre ?
Je vous invite à mettre pause et à chercher
à résoudre ce problème par vous-mêmes.
C’est un problème pas super facile mais
vraiment trop cool, donc je vous encourage
fortement à y réfléchir pendant au moins
quelques minutes. Pendant ce temps, voici
des images de mes exploits…
Alors ? Vous avez trouvé ? À quel point
la pile de carte peut-elle déborder de la
table ? 1 mètre ? 5 mètres ? 10 mètres
? Ou une distance infinie ?
Off 1. Un bon réflexe de matheux consiste
à commencer par le cas le plus simple. Je
vous propose donc de considérer le cas avec
une seule carte. De combien peut-elle déborder
d’une table tout en gardant son équilibre
? Facile ! D’une demi-carte. Et ça, c’est
parce que pour que la carte soit en équilibre,
il faut que son centre de gravité reste sur
la table, ce qui implique que pas plus de
la moitié de la carte se trouve au-delà
de la table.
En supposant que les cartes font 2 décimètres
de long, une demi-carte fait 1 décimètre.
Et dans ce cas, une carte seule peut alors
dépasser la table d’un décimètre. Jusque
là, j’espère que tout va bien. On va compliquer
un peu…
Off 2. Que se passe-t-il maintenant si l’on
a 2 cartes ? De combien la pile peut-elle
dépasser de la table ? À y réfléchir,
pour que les 2 cartes restent en équilibre,
il faut 2 conditions. En premier lieu, il
faut que les deux cartes, ensembles, soient
en équilibre sur la table, ce qui revient
à dire que le centre de gravité des deux
cartes doit se trouver au-dessus de la table.
En second lieu, il faut que la carte du dessus
soit en équilibre sur la carte du dessous.
Et ça, ça revient à dire que le centre
de gravité de la carte du dessus doit se
trouver au-dessus de la carte du dessous.
Off 3. Voici ce que je vous propose. Je vais
faire dépasser la carte du dessous de la
moitié d’une demi-carte. Ça nous fait
avancer d’un demi-décimètre. Puis, la
carte du dessus va dépasser la carte du dessous
d’une demi-carte. Le total a donc dépassé
la table d’un décimètre et demi.
OK… Mais est-ce que cette configuration
est un équilibre ?
Off 4. Le centre de gravité de la carte du
dessus est la moitié d’une demi-carte au
delà de la table. Mais le centre de gravité
de la carte du dessous, lui, est une moitié
de demi-carte à l’intérieur de la table.
Du coup, le centre de gravité des deux cartes,
qui est à mi-chemin entre les deux centres
de gravité, se trouve au bord de la table.
La première condition d’équilibre est
vérifiée. Par ailleurs, on voit que le centre
de gravité de la carte du dessus est bien
au bord de la carte du dessous, ce qui garantit
la seconde condition d’équilibre.
D’ailleurs, on peut remarquer que ces conditions
sont à leur limite, ce qui suggère que l’on
a ainsi obtenu une configuration optimale.
Donc si je récapitule, avec une carte, on
a avancé d’un décimètre, et avec deux
cartes, on a avancé d’un décimètre et
demi. Hummm... Vous voyez le pattern ? Non
? Passons maintenant à 3 cartes.
Off 5. Je vais maintenant faire dépasser
la carte du dessous d’un tiers de demi-carte,
et placer les deux cartes du dessus sur la
carte du dessous, comme j’avais placé les
deux cartes sur la table tout à l’heure.
On sait que le centre de gravité des deux
cartes du dessus dépasse maintenant la table
d’un tiers de demi-carte, et il est associé
à un poids de 2, car il correspond à 2 cartes.
À l’inverse, le centre de gravité de la
carte du bas est d’une demi-carte moins
un tiers de demi-carte à l’intérieur de
la table, ce qui correspond à être deux
tiers de demi-carte à l’intérieur de la
table. Le centre de gravité global correspond
à ⅔ de demi-carte vers l’intérieur plus
2 fois un tiers de demi-carte vers l’extérieur,
ce qui le place au bord de la table. Les trois
cartes ensembles sont bien en équilibre sur
la table. Enfin, on voit que l’équilibre
des deux cartes du dessus sur la carte du
dessous est équivalent au cas où on n’avait
que deux cartes sur la table, ce qui prouve
toutes les conditions d’équilibre.
Cette fois, on a avancé d’un décimètre,
plus un demi-décimètre, plus un tiers de
décimètre. Vous voyez le pattern maintenant
?
Off 6. Pour n cartes, je vais faire dépasser
la carte du dessous d’un n-ième de demi-carte.
Puis je vais mettre les n-1 autres cartes
sur la carte du dessous, comme je les aurais
mis sur une table. Le centre de gravité des
n-1 cartes du dessus est 1/n au delà de la
table, alors que la carte du dessous a un
centre de gravité une demi-carte moins 1/n
vers l’intérieur de la table. Le barycentre
de n-1 fois 1/n et d’une demi-carte moins
1/n d’une demi-carte se trouve alors au
bord de la table. Du coup, les n cartes sont
bien en équilibre sur la table, tandis que,
par récurrence, les n-1 cartes du dessus
sont en équilibres sur la carte du dessous,
comme elles l’auraient été sur la table.
De combien dépassent-elles de la table ? En
décimètres, n cartes dépassent alors de
1+½+⅓+ … + 1/n
C’est ce que l’on a appelle la somme harmonique.
Est-ce beaucoup ? Est-ce que cette somme est
aussi grande que l’on veut ? Ou est-ce que
l’on est dans un cas similaire à celui
du paradoxe de Zénon dont on a parlé dans
l’épisode précédent, où, peu importe
le nombre de termes que l’on ajoute, on
obtient moins qu’un nombre fini ? Qu’en
pensez-vous ?
Off 7. Pour répondre à ces questions, dessinons
des parts de camembert qui représentent toutes
les fractions en 1/n. On va mettre les deux
plus grosses parts de côté. Collons maintenant
les parts ⅓ et ¼, puis les parts ⅕ à
⅛, puis celles entre 1/9 et 1/16, et ainsi
de suite. Vous remarquez quelque chose ? Tous
les ensembles de parts que j’ai construit
ainsi font au moins une demi-camembert. C’est
parce que le k-ième ensemble contient 2k
parts, et que toutes ces parts font au moins
1/2k+1. Mais j’ai alors une infinité d’ensembles
de tailles au moins ½-camembert. Et avoir
plus qu’une infinité de demi-camembert,
ça fait une quantité infinie de camembert
!
Et donc, même si je n’y suis pas parvenu,
je pourrais, en principe, faire une pile de
cartes qui part aussi loin que l’on veut
! Elle peut même aller à plus d’un googolplex
de mètres et rejoindre mon doppelganger ! C’est
fou ! Tellement fou… que l’on peut se
demander si c’est vraiment vrai ? Est-ce
que je peux vraiment en réalité faire une
pile de cartes qui, ira peut-être pas jusqu’à
mon doppelganger, mais qui enjambera, disons,
le lac Léman ? Ou juste, une pile de cartes
qui atteindra le mur à l’autre bout de
la pièce qui est à 10 mètres ?
Et bien, le mur, il est à 10 mètres. Ça
fait 100 décimètres. Du coup, pour que la
pile de cartes puissent théoriquement atteindre
le mur, il faut choisir un nombre n de cartes
suffisamment grand pour que
la pile dépasse de 100 décimètres. Autrement
dit, il faut que
1+½+⅓+ … + 1/n > 100
Hummm… Est-ce que n = 1000 cartes, ça suffit
? Non. La somme harmonique vaut alors environ
7. Est-ce que 1 million de cartes, ça suffit
? Toujours pas. La somme harmonique donne
14. Quid d’un milliard de cartes ? La somme
harmonique ne fait alors que 21.
Off 8. En fait, au 18ème siècle, le grand
Leonhard Euler a prouvé que cette somme harmonique
jusqu’à 1/n valait à peu près le nombre
ln(n), qui est à peu près égal à 2,3 fois
le nombre de chiffres de n. En fait, ln(n)
est exactement le nombre de chiffres de n
si l’on écrit n en base e, où e est le
nombre d’Euler et vaut à peu près 2,718…
Mais je vous reparlerai sans doute de tout
ça plus en détail une autre fois.
Tout ça pour dire que le nombre de cartes
requis pour dépasser la table de 10 mètres
est environ le nombre à 100 chiffres écrits
en base e, soit e100. Si on écrivait ce nombre
en base 10, il en aurait un peu moins. 43
chiffres quand même ! Il faut donc environ
1043 cartes pour que
la pile atteigne le mur là-bas, et bien plus
d’un googol de cartes pour enjamber le lac
Léman. Ces nombres sont gigantesques ! Bien
plus grands que le nombre d’étoiles dans
l’univers. En fait, en supposant que j’utilise
des cartes ultra fines qui ne font que 0,1
mm d’épaisseur, la
pile de cartes que
je devrai alors construire fera 1036 kilomètres
de haut… ce qui est plus que
la taille de l’univers observable !
Donc non. Je ne pourrai pas faire une pile
de cartes qui ira jusqu’au mur à l’autre
bout de
la pièce…
Citer Eljj.